dafür aber sehr abenteuerlich kommen sie
mit auf zeitreise
ob er das geahnt hat
seit einstein bewiesen hat dass
zeitreisen rein theoretisch möglich sind
flitzer film nur so durch die
zeitgeschichte
ist ja nicht klar einsteigen ist der
erste teil der welt geworden
den anfang machte die zeitmaschine von
age awards mit einer spritztour in
utopische zustände erhält stolpert ins
paradies verliebt sich und kehrt zurück
als wäre nichts passiert
doch wen interessiert schon die zukunft
in der vergangenheit ist einfach mehr zu
holen findet auch simon spiegel fehlen
wissenschaftler und science fiction
experte dass durch post gegenwart
verändert wird und interessante ist dass
ich bald wird sich eigentlich rundum der
zeit reiste um abspielt villa ist da wo
eigentlich alle hebel in der hand wo
alles andere das morgen entscheidet sich
also im gestern vor allem wenn ihr
morgen die apokalypse tobt bösewicht
anni terminator schwarzenegger reis
zurück um die mutter des zukünftigen
erlösers präventiv zu töten
teil versucht genau das zu verhindern
reißt auch zurück und beschützt die
mutter komm mit mir wenn du lieben
willst damit sie den erlöser überhaupt
erstmal gebären kann alles klar
doch dabei bleibt es nicht der
beschützer schwängert die mutter und
wird somit zum vater des erlösers
und das ist sehr typisch es geht das
alles eigentlich die polin seriöses
motiv das doch eigentlich
psychoanalytisch als zehner verstehe
also bewusst eine freudig oder proxy
sind eltern miteinander schlafen und das
ich apps internet preise film sehr oft
vor und also ich dank zweier treffer zum
endstand
doch die suche nach sich selbst bringt
schnell mal probleme martin landet im
falschen moment in der vergangenheit im
falschen bett seine mutter verliebt sich
in ihn nicht in seinen vater paradox auf
die spitze der komplexität wird all das
in prädestination getrieben
die hauptfigur wird als frau geboren und
macht eine geschlechtsumwandlung mit
ihrem früheren ich reist sie in die
vergangenheit
verliebt sich in sich selbst
und zeigt sich selbst
die schlange beißt sich immer wieder in
den eigenen schwanz die logik von
ursache und wirkung ist komplett
aufgehoben der zeitreisende steckt fest
in einer vorbestimmten ausweglosigkeit
doch wozu dann das ganze verwirrspiel
sind die drei filme sind eigentlich
immer was ich selbst bin ich und wenn
ski auf sich selber treffen
was ist denn das also was macht sind
individuum eigentlich aus einsteins
theorien als nährboden für hoch
philosophische exkursionen ob er das
geahnt hat die rektoren museums regener